the World Health Organisation says no no
no no we want to stand with the
government who oppresses its people and
then lies to the working-class people
across the pond ensuring a pandemic when
ninety-five percent of it could have
been mitigated had we just done our job
let's go - right now everyone's been
talking we talked about it initially
over a week ago the World Health
Organization yes pacifically in
addressing China and now I know that a
lot of other people sort of been picking
up these talking points which is a great
thing finally but let's get specifically
into how they are synonymous and really
everything wrong with the World Health
Organization I think this is the first
time we've done it with an organization
I think individuals up until now they're
number 1 to t so if people have been
following you know they've been actually
trending this week as people they've
been celebrating the anniversary of the
World Health Organization's
founding I guess it's a celebratory
thing this what they do it was on 7th
April 1948 that Dabney Joe came into
being because I want my ambassador to be
neil degrasse tyson had sex with a
Somali pirate I'm Joe of course it's a
joke gay men can make babies oh that's
not how it works
of course everyone I'll set you there
everyone they love and they trust the
World Health Organization and that's
what we have CBS ABC NBC they've decided
to come together to air the World Health
Organization can you say who from now on
yes please do bring the foot back up I
will bring it I will be a spite foot so
everyone here stay in line it's one
world together at home it's an event
with Colbert Kimmel and Jimmy Fallon
hosting this is another example you know
they say like well this is just about
humanity it's not political and I just
don't I just don't think they understand
that they have a blind spot that the
World Health Organization who I'm sorry
I just don't like abbreviations it is it
is a political wing yes they do have a
political agenda and unfortunately it's
aligned with people who hate
everything the United States is about
you know what I really just want the
left to understand this let's not even
look at the fact that they hate America
I get it you hate America so you want to
link arms how about the fact that you
cannot boycott the gap and support an
organization that excludes Taiwan and
supports the most the most severe abuses
of human rights of any modernized
country right and I think a lot of
people may say well why it has Trump but
no this must explain why he's obviously
been bashing who for how it handled the
outbreak with coronavirus and he
threatened to cut their funding of
course the media is beside themselves
the w-h-o sent out multiple coronavirus
alerts earlier this year in fact
declaring it a global health emergency
back in January
the president largely dismissed those
warnings saying also in January it's
gonna be just fine that's a direct quote
now has been Tracy reports mr. Trump
claims the w-h-o failed they call it
wrong they really they missed a call the
president is shifting blame for the
spread of the corona virus to the World
Health Organization I don't know if it's
shifting if just keeping it exactly
where it always should have been
yeah could someone shift the dining room
tip no it's where it's always been you
shifty cinema so the anchor you see that
and you've worked in media for so long
you see what's happening there if the
anchor is giving this impression that
that who was declaring coronavirus a
global health emergency well Trump was
ignoring it right Trump declared
coronavirus a public health emergency
the very same day that who made the
declaration really an issue that he
restricted travel from China so high to
who how did they keep saying the who wh
oh no travel bans they just they were
against travel bans and they would argue
that it's not effective we listen if
your country is one big giant petri dish
and they're lying about it I think that
putting a stop on leisurely vacations is
a good start probably a good start they
were praising by the way China's
handling of the sub of this pandemic
okay throughout the entire bending over
backward let's be clear about this this
is important the timeline matters
obviously not all Chinese people were
very clear about that or hate the
Chinese government and by proxy who
because I empathize with the Chinese
people who are abused and kept under the
thumb of the trichomes can I say that
I'm Chinese economist because yeah or
racist yes I mean everything's
considered racist but I don't
that that's rich I come okay that's fine
who cares no I have no idea with this
one I know I don't you join my club
quarantine $30 off because it gets
better about may not be here so they
were praising China and it matters as
far as the Taman because all along the
way China they were destroying evidence
of the virus when it was first
discovered they silenced whistleblowers
arrested them some of them just
disappeared because they were kept in
warrant conditions plus by the way there
were studies this is something very
important to keep in mind what everyone
wants to blame Donald Trump and I
understand if you want to have the
argument that it wasn't the ideal
response of course I get that but that's
been nearly everywhere particularly
China when you see on by a studies show
that if they'd have used the proper
mitigation techniques rather than
focusing on keeping up appearances love
in the who doing their dirty work
95 percent 95 percent of the cases and
here's what matters though to has the
World Health Organization ever mentioned
any of this mitigate if it's the World
Health Organization right the fact that
they lied about the virus the fact that
they silenced whistleblowers many of
whom disappeared some of whom are dead
and the fact that they could have
mitigated it by ninety five percent if
your goal is to be the world health
organization seems to me that would
matter if there's no political motive if
the goal is entirely to solve the
pandemic why not highlight that
international abuse of power yeah
instead not only they not do it they
just keep repeating Chinese propaganda
points without question that's the issue
here by the way hit the notification
bell if you are not subscribed to
Michael but I know that many of you
aren't yet subscriptions don't mean a
whole lot hit all notifications and do
consider subscribing to Crowder bits of
course the podcast scope it's not iTunes
anymore it's not purple pod capital
podcast that's so stupid yeah I think it
makes more sense to have the toilet
robot really you're on my side now yeah
oh I never was against it okay I just
think it's invasive but I like a little
invasiveness so here's another claim
that was made by the World Health
Organization they're repeated China's
lies about how corona virus was spread
and they said that there was no evidence
no evidence of human human transmission
On January 12th now here's I want to be
clear and hold them to the same standard
that we hold everyone people can make
mistakes right people can be wrong for
example the trumpet
raishin thought that it wouldn't be as
severe as it would and that is true
right they declared an emergency same
time timeline but they didn't think
would be a severe because they were
given information from the World Health
from China and the World Health
Organization corroborated so I am NOT
mad because they said no evidence of
human human transmission On January 12th
because they made a mistake I'm mad
because Taiwan directly gave who
evidence of human human transmission in
December they provided them with proof
of doctors getting sick from the corona
virus patients it was clear evidence of
human to human transmission so why would
the World Health Organization not listen
and also go out and tell everyone else
the exact opposite because they don't
even recognize Taiwan as its own state
so here's the thing - that really does
matter with Taiwan obviously they deny
Taiwan sovereignty so they continue to
block Taiwan from membership because
China doesn't recognize them and this is
important because of the reason for
Taiwan being a separate state and that's
because specifically it applies to the
gross human abuses of human rights right
get out get out of the show map someone
who's airing in the producer getting in
the show map I have these guy and
they're like in there I will murder you
changing them so they won't even let
Taiwan have a seat at the table as an
observer no and the reason for that is
because Taiwan has been outspoken
against China this is something we've
shown before but I think it needs to be
seen as many times as possible
it says chilling as a clip gets you
don't need a conspiracy watch what
happens when a World Health Organization
official is asked specifically about
Taiwan the WTO considered Taiwan's
membership
I couldn't hear your question yeah let
me let me repeat the question let's move
to another one then because I'm I'm
actually curious I'm talking about
Taiwan as well on Taiwan's case Aaron
Sorkin is surly what horrible I just
imagine her pets hasn't worked ever if
that was the level of accountability
from every international organization
yeah you know like the UN I don't asking
Donald Trump about waterboarding like I
don't like the question and what respond
to it favorite tree I didn't hear your
question Kim yeah and she goes I'll
repeat it he goes no no no let's move on
to another one yeah it's just terrifying
how about Taiwan
how about Taiwan or were you two but you
forgot seven years in Tibet it was
pretty it was forgettable wasn't a great
the Chinese are not your friend as you
go out there and check out sweatshops
with Nike and then say trust the World
Health Organization who's complicit and
again this matters because everyone has
made people have made mistakes and say
across the board but there is a stark
contrast between the approach of the
media China the World Health
Organization and it's important to
remember that they've all acted as one
in the same right now and president
Donald Trump first off Taiwan he's
already hinted at recognizing time want
to ask he was the first United States
President to call Taiwan's president
since I think was at 79 nice since 1979
I think great year and that's sent of
course immediate into hysterics they
were furious about him and the truth is
to what we're talking about Taiwan why
it matters first off it's reprehensible
to not listen to a country simply
because you want to assist in their
oppression because you like China that
being said from him from a pragmatic
point of view Taiwan handled the quraan
over better than almost any other
country in large part why because they
don't trust anything China says hmm they
know them too well they know them too
well it was similar to South Korean
we'll get back to that in a second it
was one of the earliest countries to be
hit it has one of the lowest
infection rates and death rates despite
being right next to China they almost
entire
avoided the virus there new cases peaked
I think back in March March something
March twenty twenty second twenty four
so I'm like that population of about
twenty five million people
they've only have five deaths also keep
in mind incredible population density
we're not just talking about like why
it's spread across Wyoming here
now how did they pull this off Taiwan
and World Health Organization I hope
you're listening because you might want
to take some notes
they started inspecting passengers from
Wuhan all the way back into summer they
banned Wuhan residents and suspended
tours to China in January then they
banned all Chinese visitors February 6th
again you look at South Korea what they
did they didn't have a full quarantine
now granted they Doc's they're citizens
which you can't do here in the United
States I don't think we want to do it
here now but they acted early on and
they were immediately skeptical of any
information being fed to them from China
so this idea that it's anti Asian no no
just the government of those asked I
don't know where therefore should I just
say Asian I don't want to say cuz we
always used to say Chinese people
judgment in this case Chinese Chinese
Chinese Chinese Chinese Chinese
government only you only you not the
Koreans okay not the Taiwanese Chinese
bad by the way let's go back to South
Korea keep in mind they began moving to
create testing kits January 16th yeah
and again they worked with private
industry two weeks before the World
Health Organization actually declared
kovat and emergency so this is important
to note that Donald Trump values
Taiwan's approach so if you want to talk
about the International Committee and
you want to talk about who's supporting
people in Y all why is it racist for
someone for example to mention bad soup
or to mention the Chinese communist
government yeah but you don't recognize
that Donald Trump actually is supporting
the people the Taiwanese people who've
been oppressed by China and the world's
other disease didn't want to recognize
him but even want to talk about
recognizing I won't even let them in the
room because they're afraid of offending
China right that's incredible to
understand we do have to get to Anthony
come here and of course it's a
youtube.com slash studios America she'll
go that's right yeah good name to show
horrible URL okay Donald Trump should
cut funding of the World Health
Organization here's something else that
people aren't recognizing you know why
the working-class Americans when we're
talking about the Rust Belt don't think
that you're going in to bat for them do
you know why Joe Biden Bernie Sanders
because you don't even go in to bat for
the working class in China let alone
Taiwan these are people who are being
paid pennies a day to work in sweatshop
factories the World Health Organization
turns a blind eye the one nation that
tried to get themselves separate and say
hey we don't want to do it the way that
China does it Donald Trump says good on
you I'm going to actually try and
recognize you and support you just like
I support the steel mill we'll worker in
Pittsburgh in the World Health
Organization says no no no no we want to
stand with the government who oppresses
its people and then lies to the
working-class people across the pond
ensuring a pandemic when 95 percent of
it could have been mitigated had we just
done our job I don't think we need to be
funding the World Health Organization at
all if you want to find someone to blame
you don't need to shift the blame from
Donald Trump to world health
organization you just need to keep it
squarely where it always was Chinese
government and the World Health
Organization we are cleaning up their
mess no one's doing it perfectly but how
about we start with this
let's look out for the working class
let's look out for the underdog in this
case it's the underdog in the United
States who've been screwed by the
international economic crippling and the
underdog in Taiwan and also the underdog
in China when they're not part of the
elite ruling class and the government or
Jackie Chan shooting propaganda
commercials for the government good god
can we return can we make them included
in red dawn I can't believe that we
cater to their stupid film market and
changed it to North Korea we should have
seen the giant Chinese red flag flip
them the bird and said Wolverines
forever was it Wolverines wolveroach I
don't trust trying to try to ask
hey if you enjoyed this video subscribe
or hit the notification bell and hit all
notifications because not all
notifications work now if you just hit
the normal notification Bell I think
there's some videos playing in boxes but
of course do you consider subscribing at
a lot of credit comm slash mug club
because it's a bunch of content that
could never make it onto YouTube and I
think the box is playing there's a video
playing in a box with